نعم تمتلك جماعه انصار الله الحوثيون
العديد من الاسلحه التي كان تم استعراضها
في احدى
الفعاليات الوطنيه ف كان هذا
الاستعراض من ضمنه ايضا هذه الزوارق
وايضا ما يؤكدون ايضا ان لديهم ايضا ما
يمكن صواريخ او غواصات كانت تعرض بها في
الفتره
السابقه تؤكد ان لديهم قدرات متعدده من
خلال
تطوير بعض الصواريخ وتطوير بعض القوارب
حتى هناك قوارب انتحاريه ايضا من ضمنها
فقد استخدمت من الق من قبل في في استهداف
احدى السفن التابعه للامارات وادت الى
تدميرها في قبل اكثر من خمس سنوات ف الان
العمليه تتطور هنا نشهد ايضا طرفين طرف
انصار الله الحوثيون يؤكدون استمرار
عملياتهم في البح البحر الاحمر للضغط
على اسرائيل لتسمح بدخول الدواء والغذاء
حسب تعبيرهم ويؤكدون انه لن سيستمر في هذه
العمليات حتى يلبى
مطلبهم نشهد هنا تصعيد ايضا من الجانب
الاخر كان هناك سيتم تشكيل تحالف او ما
يسمى تحالف لحمايه بيئه البحر الاحمر لكن
الان شهدنا ايضا تراجع بعض البارجات الى
البحر المتوسط وفي ذلك بعد التراجع هذا
اكد احد المسؤولين في انصار الله الحوثيون
ب يطالب ايضا الدول المطله على البحر
المتوسط ان يمارسوا ذات الدور الذي تمارسه
جماعه انصار الله في البحر الاحمر
وان يمنعوا دخول
السفن المتجهه الى اسرائيل الموانئ
الاسرائيليه ليمارسوا الضغط ذاته وطالب
ايضا تركيا ومصر بان ذلك يكفل لهم القانون
الدولي من من ناحيه تفسيره وتعبيره لانه
يمكن ان يضغطوا من خلال الجرائم التي
ارتكبت في غزه وفي فلسطين وما يسمى بحرب
الاباده ضد اهالي غزه فطالب الدول المطله
على البحر المتوسط ان يمارسوا ذات الدور
في في البحر المتوسط لكي يتشكل ايضا اذا
تم ممارسه ذلك الدور من قبل تلك الدول
سيتم الحصار كليا حسب تعبير المسؤول
الحوثي
ليتسنى لهم الضغط على اسرائيل لانهاء
حربها على اهالي غزه وايضا للسماح بدخول
الدواء
والغذاء